right now you are looking at video
showing the arrest of terrell
rhodes by metro police for the murder of
two-year-old amari nicholson
a tragic ending to a story that we've
been following for nearly a week
thanks for joining us here at six
o'clock i'm denise valdis and i'm brian
loftis the i-team broke the story just a
couple of hours ago that the
mother's boyfriend confessed to killing
the little boy now we have team coverage
tonight
joe moeller spoke with the family
earlier on today let's begin with
vanessa murphy who was at the metro
police
press conference about an hour ago
vanessa
denise and brian well as you mentioned
sources tell me
terrell rhodes confessed to killing
two-year-old amari nicholson
and they are searching for the child's
body now we also learned just a short
while ago here at this
press conference that when police went
to arrest roads according to metro
he took an officer's gun after fighting
with them
now he is in custody at the clark county
detention center he faces charges
for murder and will face additional
charges for that incident with police
now
this is two-year-old amari he was first
reported missing on may 5th
rhodes is amari's mother's boyfriend
police say
it was clear early on the circumstances
were suspicious
and rhodes was their primary suspect
rhodes and amari's mother talked to 8
news now's joe
moeller on friday rhodes claimed a woman
took amari from where they were staying
at the emerald suites on paradise and
twain
while the mother was in colorado
what's really sickening is that people
is
making assumptions thinking that i have
something to do with it that
i have her
manipulated in some way which
that's sticking into me also because
he loves us we never do nothing like
that to him
i called amari's mother taylor nicholson
yesterday when i started to ask her
about rhodes story the call abruptly
ended now
again police have not found amari's body
and they are asking
anyone with information to come forward
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now
vanessa thanks for that joe moeller has
been following this story all week he
was with the family earlier today he
reached out to them after news of the
arrest and continues our team coverage
now joe
that's right we were with amari's family
site on his biological dad's side of the
family earlier on today after news of
trail roads his arrest broke out we
tried to reach out to them but as you
can imagine
they are upset and are not responding to
our calls we are outside the emerald
suites i'll give you a live look here at
this hour
we have seen some police coming through
here there's a beefed up presence of
security guards here at this complex and
we have been seeing
people from this neighborhood come by
and drop off candles and even a little
teddy bear out front
now the ants have been helping look for
omaree for days now
eight news now has been covering this
case since we learned the two-year-old
was missing
as vanessa just mentioned i spoke to
amari's mom and her boyfriend on friday
rhodes told me that someone from the
toddler's father's side of the family
picked him up
that family denied that happened all
along there was missing parts of his
story he did not provide a description
of the person who picked up amari
he also said when that person picked him
up they left so quick he could not get
to them
omari's mother stood by what rhodes was
saying during that interview now back
out here live i did speak to a woman who
lives here in this complex in the
emerald suite she
was one of those people who had the
police knocking on her door as they were
searching for amari trying to figure out
where exactly he was she said she was
saddened to hear about what happened and
hear about this arrest this is the
outcome that nobody wants to hear but
the search is continuing for amari's
body as soon as we
learn more about this we'll be sure to
pass it on